هذه الصور شكلت صدمه للعالم منذ نحو عامه
بعد خروج القوات الروسيه من قريه بوتشا
الصغيره الواقعه في شمالكييف عثر على اكثر
من 350 جثه بعضها متناثر في الشوارع
وبعضها مدهون في مقابر جماعيه في الساحات
حينها اتهمت موسكو بارتكاب اباده جماعيه
محتمله يصعب على السكاني نسيانها
قتلوا زوج ابنتي كان يبلغ من العمر 47
عاما 47
قتلوه ويتم حفيدها هل يمكنكم ان تتخيلوا
بعدما دفنوا اقاربهم شيد الاوكرانيون نصبا
تذكريا تخليدا لهم
القوه والصبر هؤلاء الشباب كانوا رائعين
جدا الان اصبح الكثير من الاطفال الصغار
ايتاما لكن كما تعلمون الحياه تستمر
اليوم يحلم من تبقى من سكان بوتشا الذين
كان يقدر عددهم بس 37 الف نسمه بطي صفحه
الاحتلال الروسي لا يمكننا التحدث عن
الاستقرار لكن هناك رغبه في نسيان اي شيء
يذكرنا بدخول الروس الى قريهتنا رغبه
النسيان باتت محفوره في قلبي وروحي وعقلي
كل مقيم في بوتشا وهذا هو سبب تحول
المدينه الان الى خليه نحل حتى الان ما
تزال التحقيقات الجاريه في بوتشا المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه نشرت حوالي 50 خبيرا في
اوكرانيا للتحقيق في ارتكاب روسيا جرائم
حرب او اباده جماعيه